okay everyone The Walking Dead's ninth
season released a trailer at Comic Con
today and this thing is a beast it's 5
minutes and 44 seconds of footage from
the first half of season 9 which will
premiere on October 7th
now before I run through this footage
and break down the details that you may
have missed just to remind you guys it
has been confirmed that Rick Andrew
Lincoln
and Maggie lauren cohan will exit the
show in this first half of the season so
a lot of what we're gonna be looking at
is ways for the show to kind of wind
down what their characters arcs are and
we started to see a bit of that in this
footage so let's dive into it okay the
trailer opens with Rick and negan
chatting in the prison cell now the
comics feature a huge time jump right
after the all-out war storyline against
negan after that ends up and so the show
Season 9 seems to be doing that as well
it shows Rick with his big bushy beard
he has a short hair that reflects
exactly what his character looks like at
this point in the comics and in the
first issue back it does end with Rick
walking down into the prison cell and
talking with negan so they do kind of
have these like long chats about the
nature of humanity and is it is Rick's
velocity really right is it justified
and it's some of the more interesting
panels from these issues of the comics
I'm glad the show is working this in we
also see Maggie at the hilltop now she
now has her baby finally after like 18
months of pregnancy but the hilltop has
constructed lots of medieval technology
if you look in background a lot of like
wood based instruments there's also a
windmill that you can see now she was
actually given the blueprints for a lot
of this technology including this
windmill from Georgie last season if you
look closely at this windmill you can
see what looks like the word
Commonwealth now that could be just like
a street sign but of course the
Commonwealth is a new location from the
comics and a lot of us believe that
Georgie was from the Commonwealth that
she could have been the show's version
of Pamela who leads the the Commonwealth
in comics it's a really advanced
community very militarized they have
like kind of stormtrooper like guards
and they have like an amphitheater and
just they're a very advanced community
so we're thinking that Pamela could be
Georgie on the show and that's where
she's from more on that in a second
there is also a shot of the gang
exploring an interior location with
white columns and a big staircase which
looks a lot like a place from the
Smithsonian and Washington DC or maybe
some good
building there in the background is a
Creveling crumbling facade of the US
Capitol building when they're outside so
my guess is the survivors are scavenging
this horse carriage from a DC museum
maybe the Museum of national history
there's also a shot of a camp that all
the survivors kind of live in with a
sign post and the different signs show
HQ Oceanside Alexandria sanctuary and
Toledo
I'm guessing two leaders just a joke
since you know it's pretty far west from
where they are me but the interesting
thing to me here is what community is
missing right the hilltop is missing so
my assumption is that HQ refers to the
hilltop the hilltop being considered the
HQ the center of operations basically
suggests that it's replaced Alexandria
as the main base of all these characters
which could be some source of tension
between Ric and Maggie remember there
was a scene at the end of last season
where Maggie seemed to be conspiring
against Ric and they're kind of laying
some groundwork for potential conflict
in the future the some of us had some
mixed feelings about and if you watching
this trailer there is a lot of shots
where there's some intergroup rivalry
and restlessness and people having
trouble forgiving each other but more on
that in a bit there's also a very
interesting shot that shows someone's
boots staggering on the ground as
whoever is walking in these it's
bleeding out now considering Ric only
has six episodes left we could be
looking at him here but we'll see more
of that as we get into the season
there's also a quick shot of Jadis on
the radio with the helicopter behind her
now remember we saw her character trying
to some in a helicopter last season and
this one has the same exact symbol on
the side of it I speculated that this
helicopter could be from the
Commonwealth like the one advanced
society that we know who exists in this
area who has lots of different
technology and they scavenge a lot
they've done very well for themselves
she could have some kind of connection
with Georgie but I assume this is the
same helicopter and she's trying to
connect with them again so it's looking
like season 9 we'll go more into that
arc and one of the more intriguing
details from this trailer is a series of
graffiti words tagged on the walls like
saviors save us and final warning now
save your save us probably refer to more
that unsettled rivalry between the
groups maybe that some of the different
groups don't trust
leadership and want to go back to the
way things were under negan but final
warning is interesting it looks like
that could be from a group called the
whisperers now that's a new enemy group
from the comics set we have been on the
lookout for I feel like back in season
five people were looking in the bushes
me like I saw whisperer I saw whisperer
but yeah they're a group who has a very
like tribal mindset and they do issue a
very very very serious warnings to
Rick's people in a way that I don't want
to spoil but yeah they're very like this
is our side that's your side don't come
near us so final warning seems like it
could be from them but we also see a
bunch of the new characters into this
season including magna now in the comics
Magna is the leader of a small group
from Richmond who first shows up right
after the all-out war ends she is on the
cover of the new beginning arc of the
comics and she's Dan but she's joined by
Dan Fogler from the fantastic beasts
movies he plays a character in this
group as well
but the craziest detail guys hold on to
your butts it comes in the final few
seconds when Rosita in Eugene are hiding
and they're trembling in fear they're
covering themselves in mud as a group of
walkers passed by them but guys these
are not walkers these actually are
whispers and this is the crazy steel
detail took me forever to actually hear
this but I had to listen to it over and
over again if you'd listened precisely
at five minutes and 15 seconds very very
closely turned the volume on your
headphones you can hear one of them rasp
very slowly
where
it's very very chilling and it's one of
the creepier moments when the comics as
well if you if you read the comics they
think that they hear Walker's talking to
each other but that's how we find that
out that the whispers exist and as I
mentioned there they're basically just a
tribe of weirdos whose skin walkers and
they wear the Walker skins to disguise
themselves and they whisper to each
other to try to like blend in and that's
how they protect themselves and that's
how they attack other people and when
the whisperers arrive on the scene they
are a huge huge huge game changer so
it's one of the things I'm very very
excited to see in season 9 overall I
think this trailer was really well
edited it's really excited about me
legitimately pumped for Season 9 the
camerawork and the horror imagery seems
like a big step up from past seasons and
Angela Kang seems like she is the right
person for the job to lead this show at
least based off of this trailer and for
sure the Whisperer is joining the fray
it's definitely something we can all
look forward to it's a really really fun
arc in the comics now I just have to
admit that the heavy focus on
inter-community conflicts just worries
me like the past seasons have I think
spent too much time in creating and
manufacturing these conflicts between
characters who shouldn't be fighting and
season aids finale
included that super unnecessary scene
with Maggie conspiring against Rick with
Jesus it just seemed completely out of
character for all of them I agree that
in writing conflict is important you
have to have characters who like
disagree with each other otherwise
there's like no drama there's no point
to watching the scene I just don't know
if we need more of in more and more
episodes like entire episodes with
manufactured hissy fits right there
aren't real drama between groups who
have overwhelmingly mutual interests
like I get a conflict between the
Savior's and others and I get the
conflict between Rick and potentially
the whispers and between the walkers but
like just to have characters who are
essentially on the same side randomly
pick a fight with each other just to
fill 44 minutes of runtime is one of the
bigger problems they've had on The
Walking Dead in the past few years so
looks like just based off of the this
five minutes of footage that they're
gonna be doing more of that so it
doesn't make me totally look forward to
season 9 especially when two of the main
characters are moving on I don't really
know what the direction is going forward
yet but comment down below with your
thoughts on this trailer I don't want to
hate on too much because I really did
like this trailer and it did give me
more hope for season 9 than I thought I
would have at this point so let me know
what you're most looking forward to
about
season nine what other details did you
see that got you excited there was all
kinds of really interesting things I'd
like to see the the new deaf characters
on the show and how Gabriel seems to be
blind and one I just a lot of new
interesting character details and of
course subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our breakdowns on stuff that you
love thanks everybody